[Music]
a friend is one who overlooks your
broken fence and admires the flowers in
your garden
a real friend is one who walks in when
the rest of the world walks out
a friend is someone who understands your
past believes in your future and accepts
you Just the Way You Are
lots of people want to ride with you in
the limo
but what you want is someone who will
take the bus with you when the limo
breaks down
a friend who understands your tears is
much more valuable than a lot of friends
who only know your smile
there's not a word yet for Old Friends
who've just met
friendship is the only cement that will
ever hold the world together
friends are those rare people who ask
how we are and then wait to hear the
answer
it's the people that you can call up at
4am that are your real friends
[Music]
a good friend is like a four-leaf clover
hard to find and lucky to have
[Music]
I would rather walk with a friend in the
dark than alone in the light
[Music]
true friends are never apart maybe in
distance but never in heart
friends are the siblings God didn't give
us
[Music]
friends are like diamonds Bright
Beautiful valuable and Always In Style
friends are the family you choose
[Music]
a true friend is someone who thinks you
are a good egg even though he knows that
you are slightly cracked
[Music]
a true friend never gets in your way
unless you happen to be going down
[Music]
a good friend is someone who makes you
laugh even when you think you'll never
smile again
the essence of true friendship is to
make allowance for another's little
lapses
when it hurts to look back and you're
afraid to look ahead
you can look beside you and your best
friend will be there
the only way to have a friend is to be
one
a friend can tell you things you don't
want to tell yourself
everyone has a friend during each stage
of life
but only lucky ones have the same friend
in all stages of life
real friendship like real poetry is rare
and precious as a pearl
friendship can make you a new person it
opens up new doors inside you
the kindest way of helping yourself is
to find a friend
a man's friendships are one of the best
measures of his worth
have one true friend you have more than
your share
a sweet friendship refreshes the soul
Awards become corroded friends gather no
dust
a friend knows the song in my heart and
sings it to me when my memory fails
true friendship comes when the silence
between two people is comfortable
you find out who your real friends are
when you're involved in a scandal
friendship is the bomb for the pangs of
disappointed love
once friends are that part of the human
race with which one can be human
some people go to priests others to
poetry I go to my friends
[Music]
there are three things that grow more
precious with age old wood to burn old
books to read and old friends to enjoy
one loyal friend is worth ten thousand
relatives
your friends will know you better in the
first minute you meet then your
acquaintances will in a thousand years
true friends are those rare people who
come to find you in Dark Places and Lead
You Back to the light
friendship is the source of the greatest
Pleasures without friends even the most
agreeable Pursuits become tedious
[Music]
friendship is a strong and habitual
inclination in two persons to promote
the good and happiness of one another
the friend who holds your hand and says
the wrong thing is made of dearer's
stuff than the one who stays away
[Music]
the ornaments of a house are the friends
who visit it
the ship is like money he's easier made
than kept
there are friends there is family and
then there are friends who become family
life is an awful ugly place to not have
a best friend
[Music]
one of the most beautiful qualities of
true friendship is to understand and be
understood
women's friendships are like a renewable
source of power
[Music]
friendship is the wine of life
it's not that Diamonds Are a Girl's Best
Friend
your best friends who are your diamonds
[Music]
things are never quite as scary when
you've got a best friend
[Music]
it takes a long time to grow an old
friend
a single rose can be my garden a single
friend my world
[Music]
friendship isn't a big thing it's a
million little things
[Music]
in the cookie of Life friends are the
chocolate chips
a friend is someone who gives you total
freedom to be yourself
[Music]
rare as is true love true friendship is
rarer
many people will walk in and out of your
life but only true friends will leave
Footprints in your heart
sweet is the memory of distant friends
like the metal rays of the departing Sun
it falls tenderly yet sadly on the heart
[Music]
nothing makes the Earth seem so spacious
as to have friends at a distance they
make the latitudes and longitudes
my best friend is the man who in wishing
me well wishes it for my sake
friendship is a unique phenomenon it
implies the quality of relations with
each other
envy and criticism are two toxic poisons
that destroy friendship
friends help you live longer
the pledge of friendship is a
full-fledged emotional exchange when
both give and receive something in
return
true friends are able to feel each
other's pain
we value more those friends who value us
more
conflicts with friends can lead to heart
problems
[Music]
there is a lion that cannot be crossed
in friendship
A friend in need is a friend indeed
friends develop empathy in US
older people who keep in touch with old
friends live much longer
a child without friends does not learn
social skills
the older a man is the less he believes
in friendship with a woman
in true friendship there should be no
room for competition and rivalry
[Music]
be careful with topics that could hurt
feelings
the happiest marriage is between best
friends
don't criticize your friend's spouse
walking with a group of friends makes
you more attractive
[Music]
best friends help us deal with grief
friends encourage and pushers towards
healthy Behavior
[Music]
friends give us constructive criticism
we should end friendships when we feel
empty or overwhelmed in their company
[Music]
older friends tend to give the best
career advice
the three types of friendships are the
Friendship of utility the Friendship of
pleasure and the friendship of kindness
we'll be best friends forever because
you already know too much
make friends with those who have many
friends be frank with those who have few
friends
[Music]
friendship is a wildly underrated
medication
[Music]
what is a friend a single soul dwelling
in two bodies
don't make friends who are comfortable
to be with make friends who will force
you to level yourself up
the best mirror is a good friend
life was meant for good friends and
great adventures
[Music]
thank you for watching which quote did
you like best let us know in the
comments